let's be Crystal Clear what a trusting
team is we've all been on one in the
past maybe and I hope you're on one
right now
um we've all been on trusting teams
where we have psychological safety to
say out loud I made a mistake or I need
help or I don't know
or I've got some stuff at home and I'm
struggling and it's affecting my work
product and I need help without any fear
of humiliation retribution and that'll
affect your promotability that's what
being an interesting team is and that's
what we have to build for the people who
work for us not being on a trusting team
we've also all been there unfortunately
where we're afraid to say I made a
mistake we would never say I don't know
something or don't understand something
we would never ask for help because it's
we're either going to get humiliated
publicly or we're going to affect our
promotability
um and the opportunity to build trusting
teams is what leadership is all about
um that's that's where the the strength
of culture comes from
so uh so yeah it's it's it's it's
essential to building any kind of
business short term or more long term
um but definitely definitely a long-term
company for sure and all the stuff you
talk about challenging and pushing
boundaries means if you're pushing
boundaries and you're thinking big
you're going to fall a lot it happens
there's no such thing as innovation
without experimentation and
experimentation inherently requires
failure and I think a lot of companies
that are too finite-minded they fear
failure they fear well let me let me
restate I actually don't like the word
failure you know you hear you hear it a
lot which is you know uh we have a fail
fast culture you know I I think the
problem with the word failure is it's
like the word cancer which is there's a
huge difference between stage four liver
cancer and melanoma and a mild melanoma
but they're both called cancer that's
the problem and there are failures which
are minor and overcomeable and there are
failures that are catastrophic but the
problem is they're both called failure I
like the word falling failure we should
work very hard to avoid but Falling we
should encourage because you can get
back up I know of one large gaming
company and I love this
that they they don't have parties when
they hit their goals they have parties
when they fail they have they have
parties when a game completely is a
complete blowout
because they're trying to acculturize
being comfortable with missing a goal or
or complete abject failure and they have
a party and they have their own
champagne which it has a label on it
their own label I think it's called
they're called lessons and on the back
of those champagne bottle after the
party they actually write the lessons
they learn from the failure and so it's
a comfortable it's very comfortable it's
a company that's very comfortable with
failing which means they try again very
easily and they're super innovative
um so creating a culture where we're
falling is is part of the game right I
think it's wonderful it has to be
celebrated I love it